here on wednesday um just uh always a
fun
frolic of a conversation uh co-host of
good morning football his podcast a very
popular podcast on spotify and the
ringer
is ten questions with kyle brandt
joining us back here on the rich island
show how are you kyle brandt
i'm great rich and then i had to come in
and follow the voice of trace adkins
now i sound like pee wee herman compared
to him that's no easy task well i
know everybody sounds like uh like pee
wee herman sir
uh after you know with his adults rich
he came in when we did the
good morning football in nashville when
we were doing our show from tutsis he
came in and
performed and we had a guest host and
michigan man that day taylor lawn
and he had a lot of takes on trace
adkins including his favorite song of
trey sacks which is called
honky tonk badonkadonk and uh burleson
and i
broke up dying laughing great guy the
voice from god and maybe from the devil
amazing no doubt about it kyle brandt
uh here on the rich eisen show uh let's
see where do we start uh did chris did
anyone hold a press conference today
retaining their general manager head
coach
great question i think so where what uh
what city did that come from
kyle brandt your thoughts everything
going on specifically
lake forest illinois where my childhood
bed is about one and a quarter miles
from house hall in that town
and man um i had walter payton sheets on
that childhood bed okay and uh
i've had a lot of great days as a bears
enthusiast as i call myself today was a
really kind of mystifying one i i will
say this
um this process that they're
going through is very slow
and very annoying which is ironic
because there's two guys named pace
and nagi it's it's right on the nose
and i would just say um rich i i love
being positive
about the league about the teams coming
on your show and i find it really
difficult with this team
them saying we got it the the message
today from the bears was basically like
trust us we got it we we have a plan
we're gonna figure this out
and i just i watched the packers game
never mind the saints game for a second
i watched the packers game
they're not playing the same sport as
their alleged biggest rival
it's just not there and so that's fine
you get down and you get play aaron
rodgers is great
so what are the sweeping changes i know
it's very difficult to make but
and then just get on my soapbox here to
to really
change an organization to change the
culture change the product
you gotta split some throats and you
gotta fire some good men
and you gotta do some things you don't
wanna do and we've seen it a million
times where good football men lose their
jobs and move on and
it was the best thing ever i don't think
the los angeles rams wanted to fire jeff
fisher he's a great man good guy
everybody believes in him
look at what they've done since then and
i don't want matt naggy's head on the
stake i
love maggie i love pace having met both
these guys
they're great dudes but i think in
chicago sick of hearing that and i can't
consciously come on your show and be
like i loved it i'm glad they're back
it's it's a problem and uh i don't even
know who the quarterback is and we can't
we didn't get another quarterback yet
well you got the quarterback now you got
a defensive coordinator that'll be an
important hire because
you know there shouldn't be any shortage
of candidates except for the fact that
candidates have already been hired you
know i mean so so
that's the problem here is that if you
know uh you want to make a change
um and the only coach i guess they could
have jumped on
who hasn't been already interviewed
twice or once or
or is going to be otherwise retained for
a while
um and is already on other radar screens
and it's maybe already interviewed
would be doug peterson who it seems will
be available in 2021 if you make that
move
um you know that and i feel the same way
about sam
darnold as well just to i guess continue
the script of talking about our our
our teams that we we wear our hearts on
our sleeves in our professional
uh capacities as well is is good guy
great you know great kid and face the
franchise but
it's just uh what what's more like
if if we had to put a poll question up
that uh darnold is going to take the
jets where they want to go
anyway and nagi's going to take the
bears where they want to go
anyway or none of the above i think none
of the above would win 100 percent in
that poll question
you know what i'm saying and and it's
not like that these people don't know
how to do it it's just you know times
run a course
unfortunately and i i think if you're a
bears fan
you watch and you say all right it's one
thing that we're not winning
you know we were eight and eight for one
of the players rate nine we
we hired matt maggie for his offensive
acumen
and we pretty much scored three points
in a playoff game three
like until the last walk off touched on
the jimmy graham he ran out the tunnel
right
it we're not losing 41 to 38 rich it's
they don't have any offense and he
didn't draft her biscuits
he was a step child for him that's fine
so we picked polls
spoken word out back to it's like
they've had everything
and listen it wasn't that long ago when
man the bears were good
and i'm talking about uh pre mark
tressman lovey smith bears
ran the hell out of the ball great
offensive line great pass rush and they
had something they could do it they
could beat farv
sometimes now it's like it's it's tough
to say
we got it and that was the message today
because they haven't earned that and i i
hate saying that about the bears i wish
they did have it but
i haven't seen that they do kyle brandt
here uh
on the rich eisen show okay let's let's
be more positive then let's
please love god yes i'd love to so i i
saw last week and you know you've been
doing this quite a bit on good morning
football but this one resonates with me
because
one of my favorite movies of all time is
network i think anybody who works
in this industry uh on television radio
what have you in the communications
industry it's a
it's required viewing that movie from
from
the 1970s the mid 70s and the character
peter that peter finch played and won a
an oscar for posthumously as i might add
the uh the newsman howard beal who went
crazy on the air and the rest of the
country actually kind of
uh loved it because he was a plain
speaker i mean the the number of
items from this film that actually saw
the future is truly insane
but you you are now you've taken to on
good morning football
using famous movie soliloquies and
speeches
to inspire teams and you did that for
the cleveland browns this past week
i did correct where you got a trench
coat right i assume
that's not your trench coat that was
provided to you right you got a rain
trench
so funny you say that rich the hardest
part of that whole thing it wasn't the
execution or the idea
it was i was asking anybody i could
think of do you have a trench coat
an old london fog eventually i found one
okay
a friend of a friend and it was like
that my my white whale
okay and so you it because you can't do
it without the trench coat and looking
like you just came in from the pouring
rain and lost your mind
and the neat thing is that you were you
i think you inspired you saw i saw
people on twitter like a little kids
go to a window on behalf of the
cleveland browns and scream i'm mad as
hell i'm not gonna take it anywhere
which
which means you you brought some good to
the world
i tried i thought it was really cool and
rich i think you would really appreciate
the
the behind the music of how that came
together because it's interesting from a
generational standpoint
i was speaking one of our producers
about or here's what i want to do i
think i want to do the network speech
and i'm going to pick the browns to beat
the steelers
and this this producer i'd say is maybe
30
and he says what's the network oh my
and i go you know i'm mad as hell i'm
not going to take it anymore because i
honestly don't know what that is
on the link he watches it his feedback
which i respect was
i don't know if you want to go with this
like i don't know this
my generation doesn't know i don't think
this will be big online
and i said you know what i don't care of
course i don't want it to be big online
because i want it to be big online but
this this is more important than that
this is that the message comes first
and he to his credit said you should
probably go with something else and i'm
like
no i'm not going with anything else and
here's why because that was specifically
picked for browns fans who
the young brown fans don't appreciate
what that game meant as much as the
older ones these are for bronze fans in
their 40s 50s and 60s who have gone
through this for 25 years
with the browns they understand howard
beale they remember it they ain't on
tick-tock
but they know what it's like to be mad
as well so it was picked for a very
specific reason that a 30 year old would
not understand
well it was brilliant so i'd like to set
up some divisional playoff
games for the coming weekend um what
what uh do you have any other
film soliloquies or speeches that might
that you could uh deliver right here on
the rich eisen show
that is specific to any of the teams uh
for this coming football weekend
well the um the underdogs jump out of
course
okay and uh the rams have a really tall
order
really tall and um you know i was
looking into this and
jared goff versus aaron rodgers two cal
guys was probably going to be golf i
there's a nugget there where uh in since
since 2016
in freezing cold temperatures games
aaron rodgers is 10-0 with 25 touchdowns
and one interception
jared goff has thrown five interceptions
and no touchdowns he's one-on-one it's a
miserable comparison and that's
absolutely perfect for a motivational
speech you know what i would do
i would do something i've done before a
couple years back i would do
the norm dale from hoosiers and i would
say i would break out the tape measure
and i would say the goal post right here
it's it's the same height
as the one we have in sofi stadium the
sideline is the same distance from the
end zone it's the same
same distance 10 yards i would get the
tape measure out i did that a few years
ago
when the colts went into arrowhead
during the andrew luck last run
frank reich and they had such a young
team and the arrowhead was so imposing
and i
did the norm dale speech about let's go
out and get these guys it did not work
for the cults and i don't know if it'll
work for the rams but any time you
listen to the hoosier speech it gets the
blood going when and you tell aaron
donald that you want to know
what flavor or gum aaron rodgers is
chewing right
you find it right and you go up to aaron
and he'll just look at sean mcvay and
just say dentine
something like that oh god i love that
movie it's good
i would um that's it you know the one
last year was
that for the younger audiences is the
wolf of wall street is that i'm not
leaving
and i would say that that's more of like
a favorite that's more of a favorite who
everyone says you know they're kind of
ripe to be knocked off
they're not so hot right now right i
would that would probably have to put
that one on the saints
because the drew brees i'm not going to
believe it
that would be about his retirement right
the playoffs are my home that's that's
true breeze to the team
about the idea that the bucks are going
to come in and tom brady
is going to end his season and his
career i would say that would be uh
uh the wolf of bourbon street we could
call it yes wolf of bourbon street
everybody
i love that um have you ever used the
always be closing speech have you done
that one yet
from glengarry glen ross have you done
that one you see that watch
that watch costs more than your car i
have not done it
rich it's um who would that be good for
the always be
closing who would that be for
coffee's for closers who would that be
for right now would that be for
tom brady brady the ultimate closing the
ultimate closer right
that he would just look at he'd look at
everybody and and show off the watch
right
that the rings right good team who gives
a bleep
good quarterback bleep you go home and
be with your fans
you want to work here clothes i like it
rich
i like it
and then you know uh
who would be the machine right i mean
that would be breeze beat the machine
he's passed
um i'm going to pick an upset and it's
going to get a lot of people upset as it
did last week when i picked browns over
steelers
and uh let's just say i probably will be
wearing some
brown plaid pants and uh we might be uh
in the 70s
about to go up against the soviets in
ice hockey
just get ready you're going to bust out
bro
you're going to bust out the uh the uh
kurt russell version of her brooks is
what you're going to do i might
i might let's just say i'm looking over
and i'm looking through amazon furiously
for brown plaid pants and they're
even harder to find go to the person who
gave you the final yeah i was about to
say go to the person who gave you the uh
go to the inspector gadget in your life
who coughed up that uh
that trench coat you know yeah hey
remember you gave me that trench coat
and you gave me the uh the the normdale
tape measure too now i need some herb
brook plaid pan
and after that if you could give me some
william wallace blue war paint for my
face
oh man so you know what i i mean
that's the miracle is one of the
greatest sports movies ever and and
and the reason why i say that is you
know i was
11 years old in 1980 so i remember it
like the day i i remember it like
yesterday i remember it like yesterday
when you know um we might my brother
my brother jeff was in charge he's two
years older than me
he was in charge of all sports blackouts
in in my household and what that means
was back in the day when anything was
tape delayed on television yes kids
things were not shown
live they were held off until prime time
because you couldn't put it on whatever
there was no nickelodeon's back in the
day that you could slime
you know you could slime the soviets
right so um
so we had to wait to see it so we went
into sports blackout no traffic and
weather together
my parents couldn't listen to the radio
like nothing
so i remember that to this day and i
remember what it meant to beat the
soviets and in the same way
again that we all thought that the world
series ended when the ball went through
buckner's legs there was another game
you know against the finns right and so
there was another game and that was
nerve wracking too
i clearly by stating that know how this
movie is going to end
and i'm still biting my fingernails
watching miracle
i'm not incredible it's so good and i
mean speech is so good
there there's a part of it it's a
particular line that's my favorite part
in
in the kurt russell's speech and i think
it applies to some of the games this
weekend
he's in the middle of it and make no
mistake he doesn't just say we got this
we got this we're better we're better
there's a part where he says if we
played him 10 times we might lose nine
but not this one not tonight and i love
that because there's a humility there
that's saying listen i'm not gonna lie
to you guys these guys are incredible
and i look at somebody like the rams and
the packers and i look at somebody
certainly like the browns and the chiefs
the chiefs and packers might win nine
out of ten but all it takes is one and
uh listen
i'm already getting the goosebumps right
now it's the best me too
me too it really is because it is truly
uh
a possibility we cannot sit here and say
it is impossible
we cannot sit here and say it is
impossible and um
and and i i love speeches like that i
just it's so good
it's um let me get let me pick your
brand of something rich i know you have
thoughts on this
there's a there's i'm in a i think
there's a branding quandary going on
with the league because
last week we talked so much about super
wild card weekend just electric
next weekend will be championship
weekend
divisional round weekend it won't do no
it's not it needs something that needs
an adjective
yes it needs an adjective correct you
can't just go super
by the way uh the way i always said it
it it brought wiley coyote to mind
by i always had to say it uh super
wild card weekend pretty much there it
is there's wild e coyote right there
um so dynamite
division weekend uh
i don't know other than that and then
comprehensive
uh you can't definitive that's no good
we've uh
we've taken on good morning football of
course you have trying to call it the
throwdown round
which is just something we threw
together off the top of our heads but
you can't i mean listen ncaa tournament
sweet 16 of course final four those are
all just
gold you see a little pm right next to
trademark they're good right
divisional you go to super wild card
weekend which sounds like a game show
and then you get a divisional round it
sounds like a bad geometry class i don't
want to be in so
if somebody has to figure this out and
if we did super welcome this year
something divisional next ultimate tag i
don't know the
the lots have already done it ultimate
tag elite
that's it oh man i love the ultimate
ultimate tag
division winners trying to tag wild card
winners
here they come brought to you by and
derek watt introduced
at the the coin flip i don't know i
don't know man
you're right though i've been coming on
the show for months and the
one constant yes is talking about
let's and talking about uh the movie uh
the running man that's all of the two
constants are bedrock rich it is
ultimate tag in the running
again the fact again that your your
recall of pop culture
is uh unrivaled sir but when we first
talked about
the running man and of all the
references to the running man that you
had at your fingertips
were the names of the of the three
of members of the resistance that were
supposedly uh
on the beach but we're really in a held
hostage head in the locker room
basking in the maui sun and rich i
remember them because my first ever
fantasy team was called whitman price
because you drafted dominic davis in the
first round it never worked out
dominick dominic davis was supposed to
be on the beach
he was supposed to be on the beach but
instead he was held and
held hostage i'll be back but
i guess again who one of the greatest
greatest greatest pieces of casting was
turning richard dawson evil was just
really spectacular
casting i mean it was he was evil yeah
conchita alonso was the naive
couldn't believe what impression the dog
were there and then jim brown is going
to go just
lighter on fire
all right before i let you go uh we
started this hour
with me talking about how i played a
mean game of battleship with my
nine-year-old
coop yesterday um how old are your
children
kyle i've got seven and four and a half
okay so
you're not yet there where i'm currently
but ask we play that okay guess chris
brockman ask
kyle brandt our poll question at rich
eisen show go for it
now kyle would you let your kid win at
board games
yes or no listen it it's an emphatic yes
i i just played guess who where you say
well do they have a mustache do they
have a monocle i'm making up all sorts
of nonsense
right to try to just throw the game
nevermind this was my equivalent
uh of benji and jalen hurts rich there
was no integrity into my guess who game
i'm guessing
well are they wearing a crown are they
riding a horse is just dragging my feet
till he finally got his act together in
one so it's an emphatic
emphatic yes i sud fell to the game they
sun felt
well done but flip the script ask him
the question that you thought
you know that you you asked me would
would would you
cheat yeah so kyle if you're if you're
like losing a battleship right
ask me would i move the ship on my side
yeah would you move the little two guy
around
just to you know kind of prolong that
you do that kyle
so you're telling me you're saying well
listen it ain't looking so pretty on the
high seas here i got a couple of pegs in
my destroyer on a nine through eight
twelve maybe i just slide it down to
about
12. um i think i would do that with my
wife but not my father okay well done
kyle brent
father of the year but not husband of
the year no okay definitely not
kyle thanks for the call man uh you're
the best rich thanks guys right back at
you
check out his podcast ten questions with
kyle brandt
and ringer and spotify god
fantastic i just love hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here